hello my name is Mark tercek I'm the
president and CEO of the Nature
Conservancy we're the world's largest
environmental nonprofit organization and
I'm recording your life from the goddess
I a lahmu terrace has submitted I think
a really good question for me please
tell us what you care about what future
direction you seek and how you will
contribute to improving the state of the
world well the Nature Conservancy our
mission is to save the lands and water
that life depends on that's what we try
to do it's kind of hard to be against
that but we've picked our words
carefully we focus on land we focused on
waters marine and freshwater resources
and the reason we do that is we think
life really does depend on that
sometimes people misunderstand nature is
kind of a luxury good for the well-to-do
but we rather think that it's the
fundamental underpinning of human
wellbeing human prosperity being here at
the vhost is really useful for me
because we have government leaders and
business leaders here and mostly what
I'm doing is I'm having meetings with
these people one by one helping them
understand how they can make decisions
leading their big organizations to
invest in nature like they invest in
their plant and equipment you can think
of nature as green infrastructure
infrastructure that produces fresh water
that produces food that produces clean
air that produces the spiritual benefits
of being in nature and what's great
about this forum is these business
leaders these government leaders they
get it as they look for especially with
population growth and all those
additional people demanding food water
energy space etc they see that
navigating forward will be tricky the
Nature Conservancy brings its science we
bring our 4,000 people around the world
our million members and all of our
supporters and we harness all of that to
help those folks make good organizations
to save nature to protect the lands and
water that life depends on